ich bin fast alles angefangen und das
projekt
ja ich denke auch darüber nach dass wir
einfach mal runtergeladen und auf der
bühne zu spielen
jetzt kommen wieder bei dem ich hatte
mal unter anderem ein
geburtstagsgeschenk spazieren schüler ja
verstehen dass erlaubt und wir
marschieren jetzt kurz mal runter an den
see ob ihr die fragen
max hat die fragen und so etwa ein paar
minuten laufen 1 2384 erste stadt mit
statur und jetzt dinge los mit den
fragen muss ich mich parat ich zeige
mich das gleiche wie sehen es gab schon
so krass
ich weiß ich nicht also ich weiß ihr
habt ihr euch schon mal richtig meine
kraft besetzung ich habe etwas gebrochen
gefochten die verletzte in der schlacht
sondern ich habe mal tischkicker
gespielt und wollte den ball raus holen
dann rein gefasst so zwischen die und
und diese tischkicker figuren unterhalt
einer hat so richtig durchgedreht und
dann ist mein finger geplatzt das war so
eine
aber jetzt gibt mir das hier
das von geiler ausblick
wir setzen uns jetzt nur auf diese bank
hier
ich bin sich einfach nicht an
schaut euch das mal alles aber sogar
hier richtig
ja ich denke auch darüber nach
auch so ich hab's auch mega scheiße
gefunden bis ich dann mal gespielt und
dann gefeiert
einfach stimmig ich habe nur einen
pc-bildschirm nicht richtig groß
das erste spiel was du gezeigt hast das
war in meinem fall
ich glaube ist allererste war früher bei
unserem zahnarzt mario auf dem gameboy
color damals in zwei farben und zahlen
das hat er das sei warum liegen kann
auch noch glaube ich deshalb habe ich
das erste spiel was dem spiel wollte ich
mal jetzt
das erste digitale spiele zuerst
computerspielen anführungszeichen oder
konsolenspiel hast du einen ts wo du
auch manchmal mit zuschauer entspricht
logisch nein ich bin ab und sorgt die ts
von logo also logisch ots.de dustin
kittel wurde echte idee dass eine
aufnahme erwerbsfähig gesehen wurde echt
gts da bin ich ab und zu aber ich habe
keinen tee es ruhig so oft schiffe ich
weiß nicht bisher habe ich das aber
nicht gemacht ist wunderschön hier ich
muss ehrlich ich weiß nicht ob er das
gehört aber die wellen plätschern daraa
ein bisschen dran und man sitzt sie so
ein bisschen ein bisschen eingeschlossen
und ist einfach mega cool
wollt ihr euch irgendwann tätowieren
lassen ehrlich gesagt habe ich
eigentlich das schon lust drauf aber ich
kann mich einfach nicht auf ein motiv
einigen mit mir selbst sozusagen das
einfach ich weiß es nicht ich würde mir
vielleicht einfach so ein muttermal
tätowieren lassen uns zu sagen sie ja
ich habe mich hast du dich auch mit
deinem bruder gefecht
da mobile irischen beantwortet und immer
neue fragen jetzt erreicht weil ich ja
nicht der fall klar aber würde ich kann
jetzt einfach so mal als kleine terz
euch davon erzählen was ich bekommen
habt wisst ihr eigentlich wert ist
der kurt beck geburtstag heute ich ein
samstag der tag wird klarer tag die welt
trauert das ist mir jetzt schon 19 jahre
gibt aber ich bin ich ganz cool
ja ich hab gehalt gestern abend gefeiert
da gibt es auch eine szene auf maxis
kanal link ist in der beschreibung da
könnt ihr mal vorbeischauen da hat er
gefilmt wurde nicht hätte filmen sollen
also werde ich super sacred aufnahme ich
habe mega coole geschenke bekommen also
ich habe mir nicht so viel gewünscht war
ich einfach schon eigentlich fast alles
habe ich hab halt mit dem geld eine
reparatur für mein auto bezahlt ohne
wartet es dann auch recht teuer muss er
bezahlen
ansonsten ist das beste geschenk
eigentlich von meiner kleinen schwester
so eine kleine schiefertafeln ungefähr
so wie so groß gerade in wir abbilden
guck ich so groß ungefähr
und es hat mich immer tafel und sehr
darauf geschrieben
minecraft richtig cool meine kleine
schwester dies als halte ich sag ich
euch nicht zuerst mit youtube begonnen
das war was ist denn los bei uns ja
damals
der bremer so wir suchen noch nach einer
beispiel tage die wir nicht beantworten
was war das aber ich kann euch mal
wasser werde ja als tier darüber
unterhalten uns irgendwie unseren freund
im urlaub mega die diskussion jedes jahr
der schluss war eisbär und wolle
und wisst ihr was das lustigste ist
alle wirklich alle sind einfach überein
gestimmt
dabei dass luca also konkret einfach
einen schnabel die kräfte ist so ein
start in der bibel schickes gucke ich
mir das bild an der ist ungefähr drei
jahre alt buch hat mich gefragt ob ich
schwul bin und das werde ich auch noch
wissen
wir voll wenn ihr zusammen urlaub machen
könnte jetzt nach köln kassierte ich
würde es lieben können ich würde so nach
viertel alters wg menschenwürdigen
üblichen reihen und die wird sagen wir
sind jetzt mal ganz guten länger
angekommen ich hoffe mal dass dieser
komische kleine junge nicht vielleicht
werden die büsche auftaucht und uns
irgendwie vergewaltigte was was war das
eigentlich ganz ehrlich er steht zu der
zum abschluss noch eine sache ich habe
gerade eben habe ich im kopf twitter
gepostet dass sie fragen
keiner in frage gestellt
also linke der beschreibung geht auf
twitter und volkmer und ihr könnt ihr
das spiel machen ihr könnt der hoechst
alle freunde jetzt gestellten
beantworten ok ich beantworte alle total
fall die man stellen also linken der
beschreibung zutreffen